ton père et toi vous habitez ou on est
en vacances dans une grande maison près
de l'eau au milieu de nulle part et
aussi ma mère avec nous mais ils
s'entendent pas toujours il te maltraite
non ça va tu t'es fait un petit ami dans
le coin ferme
[Applaudissements]
tu l'as pas trouvé étrange ce vieux non
pas du tout
j'arrive pas à l'ouvrir tape à la clé
pas des sept portes chelou
est ce que je peux vous aider je
m'appelle isaac je suis venu vous
inviter à dîner ce soir avec votre mari
et anna on a apporté ce qu'il faut pour
cuisiner ici c'est comme ça que ça se
passe dans le bayou alors est-ce qu'on
peut rentrer entre huy entrées
pour cette phrase sur mon ticket celle
que vous m'avez écrite vous vouliez me
dire quoi
le diable a tout le temps les yeux rivés
sur nous
certes invite à entrer d'autres non
ne prenez pas mal mais je ne crois pas
au diable mais lui croit en vous
ah non tu saignes du nez
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe je veux qu'il
parte
il ne faut pas fuir la vérité vous en
faites pas
les gens honnêtes n'ont rien à craindre
vous êtes un geek
tu es né poussière et tu redeviendras
poussière
pas la peine d'avoir peur je ne suis pas
le croque mitaine
[Musique]